of course Joe Biden himself is not
around to answer questions about any of
this he's now hiding out in the beach
for the entire week with no public
events on a schedule by the way you see
the guy there with no shirt on can
somebody buy him a t-shirt or something
anyway right before he departed uh for
DC Joe finally admitted that he actually
has seven grandkids during a Friday
night news dump apparently Joe ignored
this little girl for four years to give
her parents some space to sort things
out you believe that or was Joe
embarrassed into doing it anyway putting
that aside here with all the reaction to
today's news is Fox News contributor
Tulsi gabbard Tulsi uh okay you heard
everything that Jim Jordan and that
James Comer was saying we know now what
went on in this hearing today we'll get
the transcript later this week uh what
does that sound like to you because I
know where I grew up I have a lot of
words I can use to describe what went on
with the Biden family
well Sean let's start with remembering
the vision that our Founders had for
this country that we would be a country
of laws not of men but every single day
that we see more and more evidence
coming out about how President Biden and
his administration are politicizing the
Department of Justice to serve their own
personal and political interests ahead
of the interests of the country we can
recognize that they are directly and
intentionally undermining that very
Foundation of our democracy which is the
rule of law and they're doing it in two
ways number one specifically to go after
political opponents namely Donald Trump
Donald Trump supporters and number two
to protect themselves to protect Joe
Biden to protect Hunter Biden to protect
their personal and political allies the
American people need to recognize very
clearly what is happening here the
threat to our democracy and we have to
make the decision uh to to put a stop to
this to not allow this to go on because
otherwise we'll find ourselves in a
situation in the United States of
America where this is now the new Norm
whatever party becomes the party in
power will say hey look the last guy did
this we can use the the power of law
enforcement we can use our department of
justice to go after political opponents
and that's not perfect
but uh and I agree with you if the FBI
is weaponized and politicized that's a
problem doj I think has been I don't
think we have equal justice or equal
application of our laws as of today in
America that's extremely dangerous to
this Democratic Republic it is uh but I
want to ask you Tulsi this question we
know Joe Biden lied repeatedly both as a
candidate and as a president when he
said he'd never talked to his son or
brother or anybody for that matter about
his farm business deals uh and secondly
that he was never in business that
evolved in the last week or two he never
was in business with his son now Devin
Archer is confirming he was getting on
the phone calls and it sounds like me
that he was the closer when when Barista
most needed the Biden's hell here was
the Zola chesky on the line Hunter Biden
calls his dad dad is on speaker and sure
enough the the what they needed done the
firing of the investigator show can
happen What do you call that and Hunter
continues to get paid was that a vice
president taking uh action as vice
president for the enrichment of his
family
it it sure looks like that given the
evidence that we are seeing you take all
of the facts that you've just laid out
coupled with when when since when does
the Department of Justice work on the
weekend to send out a routine memo to
expedite getting this guy Devin Archer
uh into jail and then retracting it on a
Sunday afternoon saying oh no actually
we didn't really mean to do that and he
should be allowed to testify before
Congress they're acting so blatantly and
abusing their power to benefit President
Biden the Democrat Elite there there's
there's very it's hard to dispute the
facts that are before us it's
unfortunate that Democrats the Democrats
are trying to do that what do you say
about your former Democratic colleagues
that just oh they were only talking
about the weather but he said he never
talked about these things we only have
about 20 seconds
you know it it really sickens me Sean it
really sickens me because I know that
they don't reflect the vast majority of
the American people who really do love
this country who care about the rule of
law and are disgusted just like I am by
their actions all right Tulsi gabbard
appreciate your uh intellectual honesty
as always thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else